[Music]
who's a better soldier you're my dad
careful
come on let's go did you actually see my
dad's life yes
we looked after each other i like
brothers
yeah kind of like brothers
james they're cleaning house
you're leaving the army with an
honorable discharge but you're losing
your pension and health care
we gave them our minds our bodies and
our spirit they chewed us up and spit us
out
i just want to check in with y'all on
your past due payment message deleted
what you did in the uniform sledgehammer
[ __ ]
our thing scalpel work
we operate a deep black oga offshoot
with direct presidential authority
bank some decent cash put a down payment
on the house
that's not dangerous now i know you're
lying maybe i need to take care of my
family so what do you say you're down
for the cause yeah
study pathogenic influenza viruses in
humans
we all know what one motivated radical
can do
so let's cowboy up get it done and get
home to our families you don't
understand what you're doing i'm trying
to save lives
this is only about money
[Music]
what do we do mike
i've got an extraction team brown bmw x1
comply i'll do that when you confirm who
you're working for you work for me
you gotta trust me i am trying to help
you oh we're working for the president
of corporations
they train us to run their errands
kill their enemies and kill each other
it's easy to kill but it's much harder
to survive
need to get back home
home's in memory
he's going to come after you with
everything he's got
[Music]
i'm going home
[Music]
you